nous préparons pour le 29 avril la
quatrième manche du championnat des
yoles rondes de la martinique et ça nous
le faisons dans le cadre de la fête de
la poule de promotion du ton boulot est
de l'île de sainte marie pour cela nous
mettons en oeuvre toute une organisation
l'organisation un dispositif de sécurité
à terre donc des stands un dispositif de
la circulation mais aussi il y as avec
notre partenaire l'organisateur des
yoles un dispositif de sécurité sur la
mer avec des bateaux suiveurs pour
encadrer ces seize violent qui prendront
le départ de cette quatrième manche du
championnat sept maris alors c'est une
vision des choses qui propose à la fois
d'allier tradition et modernité
oui parce que nous aurons bien sûr
l'activité sportive l'activité nautique
dans les yoles mais avec deux régates
mais nous aurons aussi une animation une
animation podium avec avec du bellay
avec de la musique moderne du zouk mais
aussi avec du hip hop comme danser du
bellay voilà une animation mais aussi
une animation sportive avec cette
compétition des yoles à sept maris qui
autour cette marie après quelques années
bien sûr nous mettrons tout en oeuvre
pour est justement accueillir l'ensemble
des martiniquais à sainte-marie
accueilli une compétition de monde
encore à cette maille dans les années à
venir ce sera possible à partir du
moment où tout serait en oeuvre la
sécurité à terre la sécurité sur mer
mais aussi une organisation une
animation conviviale pour que les gens
soient se sentent bien c'est le baril